I'm Joe Reis I'm 26 years old and I'm a
wildlife photographer the pronghorn
passage project is one of the longest
land mammal migrations in the Western
Hemisphere
it's truly fascinating there's a group
of about 300 pronghorn that migrate
through the mountains of western Wyoming
twice a year my goal was to document
this pronghorn migration the first thing
I had to do is walk with the migration
to figure out where they were going
then I started to set up camera tracks
which are cameras that I would set up in
front of the migration and then the
animals would walk through and take
their own picture the most exciting part
was probably just to document them
crossing the rivers in the springtime
the fences and the highways were
definitely the worst things for the
migrating pronghorn
I photographed this migration to inspire
people to care about it it was very
important to me just because it's
something that's happening right in the
middle of the United States and it's
something very ancient it's something
that we all should be proud of I'm
definitely not a human centric person
when I put a wildlife first yeah I
enjoyed this just sitting in a place
where there's absolutely no noise and
you just hear birds and animals walking
around in the trees swaying and the
wounded things like that as there's more
and more people on this planet and more
people that are demanding more resources
we have to show each other the human
conflict with wildlife
you